dernière information avant de refermer
ce journal c'était pour la troisième
année les architectes en france ouvrait
les portes de leurs agents soient là la
rencontre du public tran 2 durant deux
jours cette année c'était le week-end
dernier certaines d'entre elles
s'étaient donné rendez-vous à maurepas
proposer des ateliers aux enfants on les
écoute tout de suite
grand sujet effectivement qui les
titillent ce sont toujours les questions
d'environnement évidemment et puis et
puis le prix de la construction
qui revient aussi souvent en ce moment
on a plutôt une une tendance
se soucier de l'écologie ou en tout cas
de l'environnement et donc c'est
toujours ces questions là qui reviennent
les balades sont organisées
est suivi par un architecte en général
et ont effectivement leur présente les
différents projets à l' architecture
l'histoire la mort pas ils sont passés
la balade est passé au travers de
différentes de différents logements des
années 70 donc on en prend un petit peu
l'histoire l'évolution il ya certains
équipements aussi qui ont été visités